Hello,
but the idea that giving someone a gun makes them more likely to kill people.
I'm not sure if I buy that.
When the La riots were going on,
a lot of people had their own personal firearms and uh,
this guy I know he said he had to like go on the roof of his apartment with a
gun because they were trying to break into his house and stuff like that and he
actually had to shoot somebody shot somebody in the arm or something like that.
I think he said,
who is this guy?
I don't want to say.
It might be a bullshitter.
I can tell you off air a bullshitter.
No,
absolutely not.
Occasionally,
never know.
What's the dictates like
popcorn group,
your poop.
It's not that far away.
This is
bullshit.
We don't even know.
You don't even know they're working on these things.
Nobody knows of them,
but yet they are like that close to going public and they're fucking.
Everybody has to swipe key cards before they go into the building.
They check your bag,
they make sure you don't bring your phone.
Your phone has to go into a bucket when you go into the,
into the laboratory,
because this is all propriety.
Proprietary Shit.
They're checking their.
They probably have this fucking fake buttons that are really cameras and shit.
I'm gonna.
See your glasses.
What do you want to see?
Was fucking glasses glasses.
Now they have glasses with little tiny cameras and I'm literally like so hard to
see.
If you look at your selfie camera,
look how little that goddamn lenses like the selfie one,
like the one on the back is tiny,
right?
Look at my iphone here,
but the one the front is fucking stupid.
Tiny.
It's so little and it's good.
It's really good.
I mean,
look how good a selfie camera is.
I mean they.
They do a fucking incredible job of capturing your image.
Like look at this,
look at that.
Yeah.
That's a tiny ass little little pinpoint camera and it's got everyone in this
room to the point where you could broadcast periscope from this thing that's
like a sharpie if you took a sharpie and dotted a page with it.
Just that's how big that cameras and yet it's crystal clear.
So that could be in your button.
That could be in any.
If they're not physically patting you down,
you could easily have something like that going on.
Yeah.
The one I use in massage parlors looks like a car.
A car alarm.
See you're on the air kitchen.
Oh the fuck man.
But it's a video.
I filmed a 10 80 p,
a film massage parlors.
Do you?
No.
Good.
I mean the one,
uh,
it's uh,
it's like actually just looks like a little key chain,
but if it does,
it does 10,
80 p.
like if you had a little memory card,
just put it in your computer and next thing you know,
it's just like,
oh,
you got full video.
You just put it on the nightstand next to it,
pointed towards it.
The girl hats.
Anything that's really illegal though.
I'm kidding.
I don't do it.
That's the only you do.
There's other thing you were telling me where in Brazil or I
thought was fascinating was that there,
there,
there's a new type of testosterone that they are making testosterone from Yams,
right?
Correct.
That now they're doing it through animals.
Yeah,
they are.
Um,
so,
you know,
one of the most accurate test now to use is called the carbon isotope ratio test
and what that's able to do is differentiate between natural testosterone which
all men and women have in their body and foreign testosterone because there's a
different carbon atom in that testosterone because it's made from a plant
instead of an animal.
There's now,
at least in research supply companies,
I don't think it's approved for use,
but there's animal based testosterone floating around which has the potential to
possibly defeat a carbon isotope ratio tests because it has the same carbon atom
as natural testosterone does.
Is there any hesitation and talking about these things because you worry that
you might educate cheaters?
No,
I don't think so.
I think,
you know,
I've always found that,
your credibility rises when you're forthright about what's going on.
Um,
and [inaudible] on the other side of things,
um,
you know,
the sciences,
looking at these things and always coming up with new tests.
I think something that's fact,
I just read it today,
um,
and we do this in our program as well,
is uh,
there was in cycling,
they will freeze samples both urine and blood and keep them for years at a time
and cycling just recently went back and retested some of the frozen urine and
blood from a few years ago,
uh,
for a new drug with shade,
just develop a test for and they were able to catch a guy from a couple of years
ago that had used it.
We're going to do that and UFC as well.
So even if,
you know,
there's a new drug out there that,
scientists,
chemists are saying there's no test for potentially a couple years down the line
when there is a test forward,
we'd have the ability to go back and test that.
Now maybe that athletes no longer with the UFC are no longer competing at all
anymore,
but you know,
there's still reputation and legacy at stake.
Wow,
that's crazy.
So the UFC is going to have like a giant meat locker filled with old blood and p
laboratories will have that.
Yeah.
Wow,
that's a,
that's fascinating stuff.
But doesn't that.
Well,
there's a chain of evidence issue with that isn't there?
Which just sitting around in some sort of a lab somewhere.
What was.
Yeah,
there'll be secure freezers where there is a chain of custody that goes along
with each sample.
So outside that freezer will be guard.
That's paperwork.
No,
the water laboratories are very secure.
Laboratories is this,
I've tried to get in than before.
Tough.
You're signing off your life to get in one of those things.
But um,
no.
So there's,
the chain of custody will be good,
you know,
going on indefinitely on those things.
So,
so far as you know,
this hasn't been approved where people haven't used this animal based
testosterone yet.
I believe it's being used now.
You believe it is?
Yeah.
But he came to you out of nowhere and I've got to remember the job we came to
you out of here.
You're just listening and boom,
that's the home run that people remember because it wasn't thought about ahead
of time was just listening to the mountain looking and you know,
when you're roasting people listening is also looking like taking a good look at
assessing exactly what's been put in front of you.
Uh,
when you were doing the prison thing and you talked to the guy and you said you
look at a combination of a child and a child molester.
Yeah.
You're the rare person looks like a child and a child molester at the same time.
And he did,
you know,
it wasn't like he did.
Yeah.
Nailed it there.
I just say try to say out loud what people normally would say behind people's
backs.
Hence the karate self defense.
I do remember early instances of hecklers before I knew anything about roasting.
It was just a comedian,
you know,
usually emceeing,
uh,
you know,
on the road or in Jersey,
or you had a lot of characters and in the audience.
And I remember a few times people taking swings at me or just walking on stage.
I was working with rich vos at a firehouse,
you know,
I'd only been doing comedy a year or two,
and I opened for him at some sort of fundraiser to firehouse and
I was about five minutes into my routine,
a Saturday night.
These firemen are in their firehouse.
There's,
this is,
you know,
this is before there were any rules to anything as far as,
uh,
and they kept telling me,
make fun of Larry,
make fun of Larry.
He loves it.
Make Fun of Larry and I don't know who Larry is and you know,
of course Larry turned out to be the biggest asshole on the planet who doesn't
love it at all.
And he literally was gigantic and walked up on stage and took the microphone out
of my hand,
put it in the mic stand and said,
you're done.
Wow.
Was the audience laughing before that?
I don't remember.
I'm sure they weren't laughing enough.
I just remember it being so hard and it just builds up.
You're gonna have to have thick skin and you got to be able to like stare.
You got to have confidence that you know you're,
you're in the right.